et en direct dans ce journal benoît
muracciole très investi dans ce dossier
de la guerre au yémen et président de
l'association acer actions sécurité
éthique républicaine bonjour benoît
muracciole merci de répondre à nos
questions l'organisation des
nations-unies parraine donc cet accord d
échange dans quelle mesure ils
pourraient ouvrir le chemin de la paix
comme le pensent menu c'est difficile de
le savoir ce qui sûr c'est que pour les
familles en tout cas de ces prisonniers
c'est toujours quelque chose à un moment
assez exceptionnel de mais ce qu'on ne
sait pas c'est si à l'intérieur de ces
prisonniers qui ont retrouvé la liberté
il y à des soldats de militaires qui
sont responsables de crimes de guerre de
graves violations des droits de l'homme
dans cette guerre au yémen
juste pour rappel les crimes de guerre
sont considérés comme imprescriptible et
si c'est le cas c'est soldats devront
répondre devant la justice
internationale
c'est d'ailleurs pour la raison pour
laquelle notre ong avec les six autres
en jeans poursuivant le gouvernement
français parce que ce qu'il se dessine
aujourd'hui pendant qu' il y à cette
libération des d'une partie des
prisonniers de guerre c'est que la
guerre sur place continuent et que la
situation humanitaire est encore plus
terrible parce que j'imaginais bien que
les virus des collines ne s'est pas
arrêté aux frontières du yémen
vous parlez de la france vous poursuivez
paris quel rôle pour la communauté
internationale et pour paris notamment
ce rôle a été relevé pour la deuxième
fois par les experts des nations unies
ces experts qui sont envoyées dans les
situations de conflit pour faire un état
des lieux notamment sur le les
violations des droits de l'homme et pour
la deuxième fois les experts des nations
unies reviennent en dix ans il y a une
responsabilité de la part des pays qui
exportent des armes c'est-à-dire les
était principalement les etats-unis la
france et
la grande bretagne dans les crimes
perpétués au yémen d'autant que c est à
ces gouvernements pardon ne peuvent pas
dire qu'il ne savait pas qu'il y avait
ces crimes puisqu'ils sont documentés
depuis au moins 2016 par des rapports de
deux ong ou des rapports aux des nations
unies pour parler de d'exportation
d'armes on se souvient de la sphère du
lion du barry alter way saoudien qui
avait fait escale au havre est suspecté
par de nombreuses associations ou ong
dont la vôtre d'acheminer des armes pour
le conflit au yémen
paris washington londres ont été
interpellés au mois de septembre par les
nations-unies on en est où exactement
parce qu'on n'a pas eues on a pas
entendu de réponse de notre gouvernement
en france nous attendons nous avons fait
une requête nous allons déposer une
requête au conseil d'état avant les
vacances il nous attendons toujours une
réponse de ces derniers ce qui nous
semble et ce qui est important c'est que
des juristes aujourd'hui ont travaillé
en france dans le cadre d'une recherche
sur les questions d'applicabilité du
traité sur le commerce des armes et
notamment l'article 6 du traité sur le
commerce des armes qui dit que les états
ne doivent pas exporter des armes s'ils
savent qu'au moment où on donne
l'autorisation
ces armes pourraient servir à des graves
violations des droits de l'homme à des
graves violations du droit international
mais des terres des conventions de
genève et 49 c'est le cas c'est
documenté donc aujourd'hui même ses
experts des nations unies pointe le fait
qu' il y a une responsabilité des
gouvernements dans ce conflit et dans
l'aggravation de ce conflit donc là on
attend la décision du conseil d'état 1
j'ai entendu le directeur le président
du conseil d'état dire que il faisait
appliquer la loi
au gouvernement dont on espère que cette
fois ci dans une situation absolument
humanitaire dramatique qui est détruite
et que vous avez heureusement décrite
parfaitement et bien le conseil d'état
prendra enfin ses responsabilités devant
le
internet chine justement dernière
question sur la situation humanitaire
grave la plus grave catastrophe
humanitaire selon l'onu mais mais
réellement quelle est la situation sur
place est ce que vous disposez de
nouveaux chiffres par exemple nous n'ont
malheureusement pas les moyens de faire
ce travail sur place et les grandes ong
droits de l'homme de son cul ce travail
ils récoltent de l'argent donc qui soit
autre chose
par contre le nude avait sorti un
rapport en 2019 disant que si la
situation humanitaire continuer et si la
guerre continuer avec cette ensuite
cette intensité
il faisait une évaluation de plus de
250000 personnes qui seraient mortes fin
2019 le conflit n'a pas baissé
d'intensité et sur place il y à une
situation humanitaire qui une crise
humanitaire qui s'est aggravée donc s'il
est toujours très difficile de faire des
estimations sur le nombre de morts dus à
un conflit on est on est frères
vraisemblablement malheureusement vers
plus de centaines de milliers de morts
et des enfants la mortalité des enfants
de moins de cinq ans est effectivement
utile et montérégie
merci bonne morale celle d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes le président de l'association acer
actions sécurité éthique républicaine et
vous êtes très investi dans le dossier
de la guerre au yémen